today i'm going to give you five
interviewer red flags if an interviewer
brings something like this up you know
to run the other way
you spent all this time looking for a
job you finally got a call back you
nailed the phone screen and now you've
been invited to a face-to-face or a zoom
call with the employer so here's five
things that you need to watch out for
red flags on the employer's side and if
you see one of these red flags you might
not want to take that job before we
start this if you're not subscribed
please like please subscribe and please
share this with your buddies who are
developers who want to get a good job
red flag number one disorganized
interview process hi
so a bit of a change
um so i know you're supposed to
interview sharon but sharon's on a
long-term sick leave and
carl's in her place but carl only works
every other odd number day when there's
an odd number of days in an even month
now if the even numbered month ends in
an odd number day he's here between 12
and three
um so i was gonna have you talk to that
attached but had tasha's down to
headquarters ever since there was that
fire so um
i'll find someone to interview you
okay so that's an extreme example but if
you show up for an interview and
everyone's disorganized they can't find
the people who are supposed to interview
you or they don't know where they're
supposed to be then you might want to
reconsider working there now don't get
me wrong there's going to be hiccups
there might be an emergency and some
might have to leave the meeting with you
or the conference room might get double
booked things like this happen at work
but if it seems like it's part of the
culture that there's extreme
disorganization you probably don't want
to work at that company red flag number
two trash talking and negativity you
know the last person who held this job
real idiot couldn't code to save his
life screwed up our whole system so
you'll be dealing with what he had to do
let me tell you something he smelled as
well if sea salt and vinegar chips were
a person it would look like him
yeah he got a pretty interesting resume
he seemed like a highly motivated person
let me tell you something every single
dead body on mount everest was once a
highly motivated person too if the
interviewer has a negative attitude or
he trash talks his own company that
might be a sign that you don't want to
work there now there's a big difference
between trash talking the company and
being honest and candid about the
challenges of the job if you know you're
going into a difficult position the guy
just might want to say up front hey this
is a difficult position or we have a
very difficult customer and there's a
lot of challenges in this
that might be totally fine but you know
when a guy is trash talking and you know
when a guy is being honest if someone's
trash talking their own workplace you
don't want to work there the third red
flag is rude offensive or inappropriate
behavior
it says hey you're president of the
delta zeta sorority
nice while i was in school delta zetas
were the hottest bunch of functioning
alcoholics on campus
they didn't teach you how to wear heels
if someone's being rude or inappropriate
during the interview process how the
heck are they going to treat you when
they're giving you money every two weeks
and one thing to remember at least here
in america you can't be asked about your
age your race your marital status
whether you have children so keep that
in mind if the interviewer starts
getting a little too personal which
brings us to red flag number four the
classic bait and switch so i see there's
a lot of c sharp on your resume uh just
know that this job is a c sharp
developer but it's actually 10 c sharp
50 python 50 mongodb 50 matlab and 100
backbone js oh and 50 help desk and all
of their duties as assigned so if the
job description doesn't actually match
what you're interviewing for consider
that a red flag the company may be
trying to find someone and they can't
find anybody and so they've resorted to
trying to trick someone who's desperate
into working for them and be wary of
companies that say a position is 50 help
desk and 50 coding here's why help desk
is always going to take the majority of
your time because if you aren't working
the help desk your boss is going to know
about it immediately so if you're doing
60 help desk you're still going to be
expected to hit your deadlines and do 50
programming this is how you end up on a
performance improvement plan even though
you've been working your butt off so if
a company says 50 help desk and 50
coding be very very wary of that company
and finally red flag number five we
pride ourselves on wearing many hats
here so this is a red flag because
sometimes companies need an entire it
team but they only have the budget for a
junior developer so those are the red
flags good luck on your next interview
[Music]